you got a little scared look at this
it twirls nicely with a little bit of
coffee on it they got that pumpkin spice
this is life and death right here for me
[Music]
welcome to the punishment edition of the
br gridiron punishment league lou and
amanda were teamed up this week against
flemlow and i the new underdogs being us
came back and took care of business over
scotty pippen and mj i got freaked out
late sunday afternoon jack texted me his
game oh
did you guys think the comeback was on i
had hope was it stafford and murray we
needed some big points there late in the
fourth and you got lucky thank god we
were supposed to dress up as berries i
am a beer fairy and i am father
fairy schlue just here giving blessings
i like how they both put like their
unique little spin on the costume i did
they put some thought in
the punishment for this week is to eat
the guts
of a pumpkin and i
am prepared let's get this pumpkin
eating going look at that
oh the guts i got a little hot
hot sauce i got a little salt i got a
little
prepared loose bacon lunch i don't eat
nothing without no seasoning should we
pour a little coffee in here yeah
sheer hair just like oodles of noodles
there we go
oh
what's the best part the seeds are the
guts
no no
is it sweet no this is very sweet mine
is i put a little coffee in there try to
even drink mine like a coffee i'll tell
you the hot sauce make it okay we dodged
the the perfect bullet because this
would have been the one that took me out
right here sometimes you just gotta get
a little dirty you gotta put the forks
and the knives away and utensils you
gotta just put your foot in it
man
a lot of seeds for you though i go down
easy don't come up bro i want my revenge
back they're not eating this pumpkin
they're gonna under prepare next week
that's really bad bro let's see what
happens i think after this i might
rather drink an egg how many calories we
think we're eating right now hey jack
don't say
i'm gonna save this pumpkin and i'm
gonna carve it yeah carve a big big fat
l for lou and losers all right get your
final bites in we're tapping you guys
out this is all the pumpkin i need until
next year he'll be killed right here we
shall see you in week number eight
[Music]